in 2023 Science magazine picked glp1
therapies as the Breakthrough of the
Year well known as an effective
treatment for diabetes and obesity
clinical trials this year revealed that
the drugs offered additional health
benefits but scientists were making
waves in countless ways this year across
disciplines and all over the world here
are the other notable advances from
2023 a new class of supercomputers is
here oakd National laboratory's Frontier
computer is capable of Performing one
quintilian mathematical operations per
second that's a one followed by 18 zeros
placing it in the exoscale
range researchers have already used
Frontier to predict electron behavior in
new materials and incorporate the
physics of clouds Into Climate models
more supercomputers with exoscale
capabilities are in the
works in 2021 the the discovery of human
Footprints in White Sands National park
pushed the arrival of people in the
Americas to between 21,000 to 23,000
years ago but not everyone was convinced
of this new date some researchers
thought the seeds used to date the
footprints made them seem older than
they actually were this year researchers
found that two different approaches to
dating the footprints also supported
these earlier dates changing some
Skeptics
Minds this may mean people made the
journey into the Americas at the peak of
the last ice
age the potential for natural hydrogen
as a surprising source of clean energy
got new attention this year despite
conventional thinking that hydrogen was
too reactive to exist in large
quantities in the Earth's crust the
United States Geological Survey now
estimates that there may in fact be
enough to satisfy the world's energy
needs for thousands of
years the agency along with energy
companies and Venture Capital firms are
putting putting millions of research
dollars towards investigating how to
best harness energy from natural
hydrogen
deposits a large-scale evaluation of the
first malaria vaccine reveals it's safe
and effective enough for greater use and
a second vaccine was recently approved
by the World Health
Organization while not a Panacea against
the disease that affects Millions
worldwide the vaccines do have the
potential to reduce severe cases and
deaths of children are often most
vulnerable circulation of water
throughout the world's oceans is
connected in many ways to the sinking
salty Waters in the Southern Ocean these
hypersaline Antarctic Waters pull heat
oxygen and carbon dioxide down to the
ocean's
depths using robotic probes temperature
logs and ocean circulation models
several studies this year revealed that
this fundamental process known as Global
overturning circulation
is slowing down faster than anyone had
expected researchers expect this
slowdown to
continue Collective action Is On The
Rise by early career scientists
demanding higher pay and better working
conditions after the largest academic
strike in US history at the University
of California LED to pay increases for
grad students and post STS in late 2022
thousands more academic workers have
unionized and spoken out around the
world faculty and administrators in turn
Face the challenge of finding short-term
ways to cover increased Personnel costs
while long-term funding strategies are
still
unclear by monitoring dying Stars called
pulsars physicists detected the
strongest evidence yet of two super
massive black holes
merging pulsars are known for the
regularity of the radiation pulses they
emit astronomers monitor these pulses
using radio telescopes to detect tiny
changes in their Rhythm that could
indicate a gravitational wave passing
through while hesitant to call it a
discovery until it's further confirmed
Pulsar timing arrays offer a promising
way to observe some of the most massive
objects in the
[Music]
universe us Regulators have approved the
first drug that could slow down the
cognitive decline from Alzheimer's
disease the new treatment lanat targets
the Tangled protein clumps found in the
brains of people with
Alzheimer's but treatments like these do
come with risks like swelling and
hemorrhaging in the brain researchers
are still dialing in on whether this
slowing of cognitive decline increases
as people take the drugs for longer and
whether it can delay the start of
symptoms for people likely to develop
the
disease for decades forecasting the
weather meant crunching numbers and
equations to predict changes in the
atmosphere this year multiple technology
companies have succeeded in using a
different approach AI modeling instead
of solving equations the AI models find
patterns and past data to predict
weather up to 10 days in
advance these new models are faster at
forecasting require less computing power
and sometimes are even more accurate
than traditional
models researchers expect AI models will
improve even more once they start to
learn from direct web observations not
just past
data that wraps up our list of notable
achievements from last year and we're
already looking at what's coming in
2024 a new planetary Mission an ongoing
elmino and a mosquito bacterium could
make the next year another interesting
one for
[Music]
science